renew tensions in the Eastern
Mediterranean turkey is under Fire for
resuming exploration for oil and gas and
Israel and Lebanon are arguing over
Maritime rights so can these disputes be
contained and does diplomacy still have
a chance this is Inside
Story
hello and welcome to the program I'm
dine abuga turkey's renewed seismic
survey in the Eastern Mediterranean is
reigniting tensions with Greece both
NATO members claim the right to drill
these same areas believed to be rich in
natural gas Athens considers the
redeployment of a Turkish vessel in
disputed Waters a major escalation and
says it'll push for EU sanctions against
turkey ankora insists the the operations
are within its continental shelf and
it's responding to provocations by
Athens it had pulled the vessel out of
the waters last month saying it would
encourage diplomacy but president reab T
berdan says Greece and Cyprus have
failed to fulfill their promises and now
the Turkish leader has threatened to
take
action we will continue to give the
response they deserve in the field to
Greece and the Greek cypriot administ
ation who have not kept their promises
during talks within the EU and NATO
platforms well both countries had agreed
to hold preliminary discussions to ease
the dispute earlier this month but the
Greek Prime Minister kiriako mitsotaki
Says Athens won't engage with ankora as
long as the vessel remains in the
region I think we offer turkey a very
clear choice at the recent European uh
Council uh renewed partnership or face
consequences should this aggressive
behavior uh continue and unfortunately
it seems for the moment that turkey uh
has uh chosen the second
path let's bring in our guests joining
us from Istanbul is Matthew brza who's a
senior fellow at the Atlantic Council
and a former US Diplomat who worked on
the Greece Cyprus and turkey issues at
the US state department over in London
is James kinsay who's a visiting
professor at the London School of
Economics researching Greece turkey
relations and the Cyprus conflict and
over nican Cyprus Andreas Theos who's
the president of the cypress center for
European and international Affairs and a
former economic adviser to the President
of Cyprus welcome to Inside Story thanks
very much for your time Matthew briza
turkey has now redeployed uh that vessel
to disputed Waters what message is it
sending out by doing so I think what
president ardan is doing is saying um
you know we were hoping that there were
going to be some de-escalatory talks
under the opes of NATO European Union um
and well the way the government here has
plated is that they they were upset when
uh last week the Greek government issued
a navtech so a notification that they
were going to conduct Naval exercises in
the aanc uh and on on turkey's National
Independence Day that's that's a it felt
like a you know a raw nerve was touched
because that that Independence Day is
actually commemorating the end of a war
fought between turkey on one side and
then Greece and the United Kingdom and
others on the other side right but let
me ask you this erdogan said this and I
quote we will continue to give the
response they deserve on the field to
Greece and the Greek Superior
Administration who have not kept their
promises during talks within the EU and
NATO
platforms will what are these
responses yeah and I don't know exactly
what he has in mind because I don't know
what transpired in those discussions but
my my understanding is that the talks
were going okay and the idea was let's
deescalate tension uh and let's have a
discussion about this legal dispute from
the Turkish perspective which is murky
it's it's not a concrete black and white
uh situation as to who's right who's
wrong so in terms of responses I I I
think what he means he's being you know
potentially dangerously ambiguous
suggesting there could be military force
involved but what I think he means is
that the seismic survey ship Auto Trace
is going to continue it its exploration
the drill ships are going to continue
their exploration uh and and they're
going to be probably accompanied by
Turkish navy vessels uh James again
let's just focus in on what the
president of Turkey had to say when he
says that Greece and the Greek supri
Administration have not kept their
promises he didn't spell out what those
promises exactly were from your your
understanding uh James what does he mean
by this well you know it's a very
confusing situation all around because I
I think the point that was just made was
was was very good that it was to say uh
turkey has a particular viewpoint on uh
the nature of these disputes um it also
has a very particular viewpoint on how
these disputes should be addressed uh
namely in bilateral negotiations but the
big problem that we're seeing uh is that
it's using what is seen by many
Outsiders to be an overly aggressive
tactic uh to try and bring Greece
certainly uh to the negotiating table um
and so it and it's very unclear to know
exactly what erduan means on on any
given day on on a lot of issues um so
what he might have in mind um is is
probably not what a lot of uh turkey's
Partners uh in NATO and certainly the
European Union have in mind for how we
should be dealing with these disputes at
the moment yeah we we'll certainly get
into the discussion of NATO and the EU
but let me ask you James then what
Greece has in mind because uh Matthew
RZA just correctly pointed out out that
Athens did hold military drills in the
aanc on one of turkey's main national
holidays so what's behind that message
and what is the message that Athens are
sending out well look I mean I I think
the important thing to bear in mind is
that you know there is quite a long
history of Greece and Turkey needling
each other on various issues and things
um but what we're seeing here is uh a
Resurgence of a dispute between Greece
and Turkey that we had felt um had
actually dissipated to a certain extent
over the past 20 years over the past
five years it's been getting steadily
worse I think um and what we're seeing
now is that crisis but you know we were
looking 20 years ago at a major process
of rap roson where it looked like there
might be a wind of opportunity for the
two countries to start to address these
bigger issues and that's now disappeared
and one thing that really stands out for
anyone who works on these sorts of
issues is that it's so much easier to
address these sort of Maritime disputes
if there's an element of Goodwill and
trust between two countries lots of
countries have Maritime disputes what
we're seeing here is a gradual
ratcheting up or or quite a significant
ratcheting up of the tensions between
the two countries which is just creating
if you like a vicious circle which makes
it more and more difficult for them to
sit down and not even work out how
they're going to you know what they're
going to do to solve the problem but how
they're even going to talk about solving
the problem uh Andreas let me bring you
in from nicasia and we're also going to
get into the issue of Cyprus in a moment
um but first of all just weigh in on the
situation between Greece and Turkey is
there any Goodwill at this point to
resolve
issues good willll from whom I think
over time I think over time Athens has
been exhibiting um Goodwill and it was
supporting turkey in its European
Ambitions expecting that there would be
reciprocal steps that did not happen and
uh talking from nikosia in relation to
Cyprus well we must not forget that for
46 years turkey is occupying 38% of the
territory of Cyprus it has been
provoking you know invading the
exclusive economic zone of Cyprus
recently in Brussels there were no
sanctions against uh turkey instead the
EUR European Union called for uh talks
and would wanted to see a process
through which problems in the Eastern
Mediterranean would be resolved turkey a
few days after that it it took a step in
relation to the fence city of Barosa and
it is moving towards opening that which
is contrary to the United Nations
security Council resolutions all in all
from our perspective we see that turkey
terion is power you know erdogan himself
does not conceal this fact he has
repeatedly declared that he would like
to see the Treaty of Lan um revised in
relation to Cyprus he does not you know
he has stated many times that he
consider he does not recognize the
Republic of Cyprus and its right to exit
to exist yet when it comes to the
Eastern Mediterranean it
invokes um part of the 1960 agreements
to demand to you know rights for turkey
and the Turkish cots well at the same
time time for getting obligations I
think at this point in time I think at
this point in time um there is uh what I
would say a lot of Suspicion uh mistrust
and the climate is not it's not positive
I understand on the other hand that uh
major powers in the European Union as
well as the United States would like to
see some form of a dialogue in order to
EAS tensions but it takes two to tango
okay let's talk about the EU for a
moment Andreas I'll stick with you for a
second second because the EU as you
pointed out did threaten turkey with
sanctions if it according to the EU uh
failed to stop what the block was
describing as illegal Drilling and
energy exploration activities in this
particular area in the Eastern
Mediterranean uh but now the voices are
growing again uh for sanctions but do
you actually think the EU will be going
down that route and do does the EU all
speak in one voice when it comes to
Turkey certainly not I mean like the
European Union has not yet developed
into a geopol IAL power that it will
have a strong and unanimous say in the
Eastern Mediterranean or elsewhere but I
think in the case of Cyprus uh we can
think outside the box let me let me put
on the table some
suggestions um turkey would turkey and
the Turkish cypriots would like to see
cooperation between Greek cypriots and
Turkish cypriots on the energy issues
even before the solution of the Cyprus
problem uh I think it would be good if
that is going to take place uh turkey
should agree to delineate the exclusive
economic zone between Cyprus and turkey
and at the same time uh move on with the
implementation of the relevant Security
Council resolutions on vosa that is
allow the Greek cot legal residents of
varia to return under the opes of the UN
I think under under a such a scenario
where we have some small major steps
towards cooperation at least that would
uh it may create a positive climate
reduce tensions and at least try to
build on some confidence okay let me
stop you right there for a second James
James would you like to jump in yes we
can be very honest and and say look it
sounds nice to have competence building
measures um but I've been working on
Cyprus for 30 years and I can tell you
that all confidence building measures do
is actually reduce trust we need to be
focusing on an overall settlement so the
idea that you're going to get a Greek
and Turkish Cates to sit down and reach
a comprehensive deal on
energy and not do a big de I just can't
see it happening and all we're going to
do is get drawn into this debate um for
another couple of years um where the
Cypress problem as a whole um is just
going to sit and languish and they're
going to talk and talk and talk talk
around the issues it won't achieve any
successful outcome so so what what are
you what are you
proposing I think that you know we
really need to be focusing on what we
should always be focusing on which is a
comprehensive settlement of the Cyprus
problem uh that once you get the parties
together to sort this issue all these
issues get resolved at a stroke you sold
the Cypress problem you will be talking
about the effective recognition of the
entire island of Cyprus its territorial
waters you know there may be some issues
that will need to be sorted out with
anchor but it becomes much more
manageable than trines peac meal um sort
of competence building measures the
history of the Cyprus problem has shown
that competence building measures
actually do more more harm than good um
very little ever comes out of it and it
just undermines trust so I I I really do
think that what we need to be doing is
focusing on how we're going to get the
sides back to the negotiating table
there's major elections coming up in
Northern us this weekend which might
provide a chance for a resume un
negotiation process and this is
effectively I think where we need to be
focusing
Matthew it very much sounds like I may
yeah go ahead go ahead Andreas and
Matthew I'll come over to you in just
one second go ahead Andreas I I have
made these suggestions because what
James is suggesting that took place for
46 years and it didn't work out uh that
did not work the policy pursued so far
and in relation to the Cyprus question
we must see that the UN process for
intercommunal negotiations uh by
communal negotiations IT addresses only
one dimension of the problem yet the
major problem is the fact that turkey is
occupying uh 38% of the ter of ter of
Cyprus it has more settlers it has put
settlers on the northern part of the
island Turkish cypriots are less than
50% minority even in the northern part
of Cyprus so I think even the process
that we have worked so far didn't work
turkey used this time all this this him
to consolidate in defao situation uh I
was born with the Republic of Cyprus in
1960 I'm aware that James has been doing
a lot of work in Cyprus but I'm living
here and I have experience step by step
what has taken place all these years and
um our perception is different yes it
would be it would be great to see a
comprehensive settlement and I think
over time Greek cypriots have made uh
concessions that that nobody would have
been thinking of for example uh we're
just right I just to say something yeah
okay um I mean it's 2 to1 so please
allow me I mean in relation to what we
have considered in Cyprus if Turkey were
if Turkey were to offer what Greek
cypriots have offered to the Turkish
cots I think there would be no cish
problem in Turkey as well okay I
understand what you're saying about the
issue of Cypress uh Matthew let me bring
you in because obviously the discussion
is heading into this uh the differences
when it comes to to the island of
Cypress so there are many issues at play
here but let's just get back to the
issue of gas and energy resources and
mediation efforts because uh we've seen
kind of an absence by the US when it
comes to this Germany has sought to
mediate between Greece and Turkey uh
France has weighed in as well but it's
weighed more explicitly on the side of
the Greeks to what extent can diplomacy
be achieved at this point and by whom
yeah I think at this point we are at an
impass I mean going back to what Mr the
was saying and James as well um there
all these years 407 years 46 years of
trying to reach a comprehensive solution
and I think that um two years ago when
the or three years ago when the last
round of un mediated talks collapsed I
think turkey kind of gave up because as
Mr theophan says he sees the Greek
cypriots as having made significant uh
uh concessions the Turkish side thinks
it did too in including to withdraw all
of its troops from the island so the UN
process I think is kind of dead the US
is absent and I think what we've seen
throughout the course of the summer is
that the the biggest outside player
right now is France and it's been it's
been president Marron who has a lot of
enmity with or toward president erogan I
mean France and turkey have squared off
on different sides in Syria uh and in
Libya now in aeran and so I think the
mediator I would ultimately have to be
the European Union as a whole unless the
UN could get back involved but right now
the prospects of mediation I think are
really remote well okay speaking of the
US and where it hasn't been absent is
there's another dispute on Maritime
rights in the Eastern Mediterranean and
that's between Lebanon Israel so they've
started their first round of indirect
talks on gas exploration rights at stake
there are more than 860 square kilm of
waters that both claim are in their
exclusive economic zone the first
session on Wednesday was hosted by the
United Nations it was mediated by the us
and it marks a first step in efforts to
demarcate Maritime borders between those
two countries James so uh the US clearly
involved in these Maritime discussions
between uh Lebanon and Israel so another
source of tension in the region do you
expect a break through there well I mean
you know we we're dealing with a you
know a a very very different environment
than a lot of us who have spent many
decades working on Eastern Mediterranean
are actually even frankly used to and
trying to uh get our heads around
because uh the whole patterns of
relationship um in in the region have
have fundamentally altered now I can
remember in the 1990s that if you looked
at the geopolitical environment in in
the Eastern Mediterranean uh the two
best friends were turkey and Israel uh
that there was absolutely no love lost
whatsoever uh between the Republic of s
and Israel or even between Greece and
Israel and then now you look at this
situation where everything's been turned
on its head um and now we see uh Cyprus
is uh really buddying up there's a
there's a loving effectively going on
between Cyprus and Israel and and Greece
and Israel uh turkey Israeli
relationship is well that that's that's
that's past history um and then now
you're starting to see things like talks
between Israel and Lebanon which I I
think many people would have felt would
have been just completely Beyond The
Pale even a few years ago right indirect
talks we must point out though these are
indirect talks how things are changing
okay James I'll stick with you for one
more question then do you agree with
Matthew then at this point it has to it
has to be talks under the UN offices or
the EU members when it comes to Greece
and Turkey and can the EU be objective
here with both Greece and Cyprus being
members well I I think you know this is
where we get into the sort of
problematic picture because although we
tend to lump Greece and turkey's issues
along with Cyprus they are actually
rather different from each other um the
the question of Cyprus uh is you know I
think Andrea said it was about Invasion
occupation to an extent yes it is but
you know that ignores the fact that
there's a fundamental issue between
Greek and Turkish cypret and I think you
know it's it's unfortunate to just count
out the Turkish cites in that way um but
when you talk about the issues between
Greece and Turkey these are much more
legally centered uh essentially Greece
and Turkey sorted out their boundaries a
100 years ago under the Treaty of loan
what we've seen is the development of
international law and um the fact that
Greece and Turkey need to be able to
find a way um to talk about their
boundaries now that the extent of
territory that they can claim is very
different under international law and
this is the problem um and I think there
is room uh for Greece and Turkey to sort
out their problem again a lot of it's to
do with Goodwill you know if there's
Goodwill and there's trust and that they
can sit down and they can really talk
about it and the really big issue is a
tiny island of
castellorizo um which I probably won't
go into a lot of detail here but it it
it means that effectively Greece
suddenly gets another big chunk of the
Eastern Mediterranean which turkey feels
is fundamentally unfair um so it's how
they sorted out can they negotiate and
then take it to the international court
of justice or do they try and get some
sort of legal arbitration from day one
or just stick to negotiations so at the
moment they aren't even finding ways to
talk about how to talk about their
problems Andreas does NATO step in here
can NATO play that mediating role I mean
there have been about 60 rounds of talks
in the space of 14 years between Greece
and Turkey and they've brought little
progress and now we're in a position
where uh talks are just completely
stalled yeah before before I get to your
before I get to answer your question uh
let me say that I think Mr pres should
you know update and correct his its
facts I think if Turkey were to agree to
withdraw its troops from Cyprus and also
agree that there should be a different
uh guarantee status uh for example
Security Council to to guarantee the
Republic of Cyprus that it would be a
big step towards resolving the Cyprus
question I think that this is perhaps
the most thorny issue that turkey is not
giving up its right to be its so-called
right uh with inverted without inverted
commas to be in Cyprus that's Point
number one just stand by for a second
Matthew would you like to respond yeah
those are the two points T turkey giving
up its right of guarantee and turkey
agreeing to withdraw all of its troops
over time over the island when I was
involved with the so-called Anon plan
back in the early 2000s that those were
the final sticking points and I'm not
going to Deva sources but I can say I
know from High up in the UN apparatus
people who were in The Talks that turkey
did in fact put those two things on the
table and Cyprus rejected it so I think
at that point turkey said okay why go on
Mr I know for fact that Anan plan it had
to do with the future of my
country the fact that 76% Greek cypriots
voted no it's indicative of an a Very
uneven and just plan you know very well
Mr Andre just for the sake of time just
tell me how you see this going forward
in terms of mediation My Philosophy is
that given the fact that for 46 years we
tried the SE Pro it didn't work out my
philos philosophy is that we should try
an evolutionary process which should go
side by side with trying to address the
trying to reach a
comprehensive uh solution of the problem
it's not or the other that's why I'm
suggesting I'm bringing this to the
table I'm and I'm academic and you know
I suggest that um I made some
suggestions which I think it could be a
good starting point to move on to agree
to something reduce tensions and that
would reinforce goodwi towards resolving
the Cyprus question I think um in
relation to Nato turkey it's part of
NATO Cyprus is not part of NATO that may
create a problem I think so we have the
European Union we have the security
Council uh of the United Nations I I
think uh this should be addressed in
this way and for me it's not either or
it's very clear in the case of Cyprus
what is been taking place you know
cypriots who have
experienced um all these years we know
that turkey you know it does not
recognize the right of the Republic of
Cyprus to exist we have on record
Turkish officials saying that even if
one single Turkish cot did not live on
the island of Cyprus turkey would still
want to have an a strong say on
developments on the island okay
unfortunately we'll have to leave it
there on that note thank you very much
for joining us Matthew brza James kinsay
and Andreas Theos thank you very much
for your time with us thank you for
watching you can see the program again
anytime by visiting our website al.com
for further discussion you can go to our
Facebook page that's facebook.com AJ
Insight story you can also join the
conversation on Twitter our handle is AJ
Insight story from myself and the whole
team here in Doha thanks very much for
watching and goodbye for
[Music]
now